[موسيقى]
الان متواجدون في بلده ستروجوفا هذه
البلده هي من بين البلدات التي استعادت
القوات الاوكرانيه السيطره عليها في جنوب
مقاطعه دونيتس وانسحبت منها القوات
الروسيه نحن في هذا المنزل الذي على ما
يبدو انه كان منزلا تحتمي فيه القوات
الروسيه هذه بعض
المستلزمات وبعض
المواد الغذائيه الخاصه باكوات الروسيه
يبدو ان هذه المنطقه شهدت معارك عنيفه بين
الذين تواجدوا في هذا المنزل وبين القوات
الاوكرانيه نشاهد هنا اثار هذه الرصاصات
التي كانت على ما يبدو لي الجنود هنا هذه
الرصاصه على سبيل المثال اخترقت هذا
الحائط هنا واثار كثيره
للدمار في هذا المكان كما ستشاهدون هذا
المنزل المدمر بالكامل
وبسبب القصف والقصف المتبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
نشاهد اثار هذه المعارك ولكن المعارك لم
تنتهي في هذه المنطقه كما تشاهدون هذه
ايضا القوات الروسيه في هذا المكان
المعارك ما زالت مستمره بالقرب من هذا
المكان في احدى البلدات القريبه بلده
ماكاريكا تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها
استعادت السيطره عليها لكن القوات وسيله
تحاول ان تعود اليها لذلك نسمع بين الحين
الاخر اصوات القذائف بشكل متواصل باتجاه
هذه المنطقه القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان
تنفذ الهجوم المضاد لكن يبدو ان هناك
مقاومه شرسه من الجانب الروسي ولكن
المعارك مستمره في هذه الهجمات المضاده
هنا في جنوب مقاطعه نيسك وكذلك في
جنوبولوجيا